[Musique]
là
hello
oh
[Musique]
o o
banyuls des médias note chez éric morena
ribas pagne à la beauté qui nous mener
loin du monde ce n'est pour de l'aimer
comme il agacé le mans
photographier les bébés l'eau des
papilles des vagues à pagaie et moi
t'aimer crient leur bonheur
[Musique]
m
oh
[Applaudissements]
sacrées du monde
le plus beau
[Musique]
tout s'est enchaîné
c'est pas pour les alouettes
g
oh
je serai bientôt trente ans les riffs et
sauvage mais les algues la soul comme
témoin au magro
oh
m
ouais le plus beau des bateaux
[Musique]
nu sous le ciel étoilé le royaume les
deux bonhommes
c'est les poissons centre
il rêvait
crowley
[Musique]
m
mais bon
c'est bon
mais la pluie bonté
m
ah non
[Musique]
il est plus fort
[Applaudissements]
jean françois kahn bonsoir pierre juquin
bonsoir vous présente le 110 alors vous
connaissez tous les deux bah oui j'ai
croisé 3 et où le journal alors on verra
quoi qu'il en soit il a dû en prendre
beaucoup alors jean-françois est-ce que
par les musiques mnm aux figures oui y'a
blandine est la même que chez jean
françois est ce que le magazine paroles
et musique que tu sors à la fin du mois
qui est nouveau magazine du groupe de
l'événement un groupe
est-ce que vous parlerez du retour des
rythmes latins aujourd'hui le jeune qui
aime le rock et même le hard rock qui
peut aimer souchon il peut aimer
gainsbourg il peut trouver formidable et
amusant eric morena eric morena je crois
que c'était vraiment c'était vraiment
nario moral j'ai connu lario moreno j'ai
cru droite et c'est donc c'est que si
vous voulez et je peux y aller et des
mensuels dans ses droits précédera je
crois qu'il ya besoin aujourd'hui d'un
grand mensuel de toutes les chances or
tous les rides toutes les musiques en
fête pour les jeunes ce sera généralise
tout ce qui est des chansons qu'ils
aiment le rythme qu'on soit quels sont
les autres projets du groupe de
l'événement parce que je sais ça prend
des proportions assez le plus important
celui là parce qu'on veut vraiment faire
si vous voulez à la chanson ce que
première est aussi les mains ou faire
disons le salut les copains mais de la
génération d'aujourd'hui les jeunes
d'aujourd'hui tiers des jeunes qui en
plus à travers la chanson des choses à
dire a alors qu'à 25 ans il ya 25 ans il
avait rien à lire à travers et chansons
ou plutôt il disait qu'il n'avait rien à
dire
aujourd'hui ils ont toutes leurs colères
leurs joies leurs aspirations exprimées
dans la santé oms tu vas finir
commerçants avec un groupe de bresse
alors citizen kane maintenant venir
tu vas remplacé polac ou à la télé non
pourquoi que j'ai trop ça t'aurait plus
si tu avais le temps j'aime beaucoup la
télé mais enfin pour tous ses pôles
trouvez pas qu'il serait bientôt
remplacé polac vis-à-vis de paula je
dirais qu'il est irremplaçable gens d'y
retourner en france fois qu'un
maintenant on va regarder le l'authentic
dario moreno donc il chante si tu vas
dario
[Musique]
siphiwe azaria
mais pas de monter là haut
là
m
cette amadou les là
sortir des maisons
à la fois
et tu veux
des fruits à la taille fine à manger un
petit phare et les bombes à l'entrée
sammer allumé le florida quelle rigolade
et aux morts
qui prépare le pas
souvent pour un quart
allumez la can
et tu peur
et puis à la traîne
avant j'ai un petit pain et les pauvres
dans ce joyeux tintamarre allumé le
professeur des écoles et les chambres
si tu vas à rio
n'oublie pas le monde tu es là dans le
petit village
m
si tu azaria
c'est la vie
si tu vas à rio
alors pierre juquin vous avez vous êtes
entré au parti communiste en 53 vous
avez supporté l'époque déjà
d'interruption elle en allemagne de
l'est à berlin vous avez supporté
budapest 156 tchécoslovaquie en 68 vous
avez participé à l'exclusion d'un
certain nombre de vos camarades et
aujourd'hui quel effet ça fait d'être
exclue vous même ce n'est pas mon
principal problème parce que je compte
la situation beaucoup évolué depuis
d'autre part il ya deux ans j'ai écrit
un livre qui s'appelait autocritique et
ça n'est pas de la frime
j'essaie de faire le bilan de tous a dit
réfléchir vraiment et j'avais deux
solutions ou me mettre à écrire des
romans ou des essais ou essayer de
repartir je ne dirais pas et romain
tenant compte de tout cela et de tout ce
qui s'est fait en dehors de moi pendant
ce temps pour continuer une bataille
disons humaniste vous rejoignez la
cohorte des repentis du pc finalement
authentique je trouve ce mot très
mauvais je vais vous dire pourquoi
peut-être pas que je veux ce que vous
pensez vrai parce que moi je ne suis
jamais rentré dans le communisme comme
rentre dans une église
je pense qu'il faut enfin laïcisé ce
genre de politique dans le parti
communiste
j'ai beaucoup appris moi qui suis un
intellectuel évidemment d'origine très
modeste et tout là-bas intellectuelle et
j'en suis fier et heureux
je voudrais l'être encore plus j'ai
rencontré là des gens de tous les
milieux du monde du travail
je me parlaient les coeurs mineure -
cheminots ont directement ce formidable
quand on lui parle d'argent que vous
avez vous avait exclu à l'époque où des
choses insupportables que vous avez
supporté
vous le regrettez part il aura rendu
service
il a permis au parti claude françois
kahn qui vient d'expirer genre
d'explosion j'en ai pas tellement
exprimé j'ai couvert des types de
politiques non je pas exclu à la crise
j'ai couvert un petit lieu les étudiants
communistes et en 65 une bataille j'ai
couvert un type de politique et dans les
comités qui est très préjudiciable la
cause de qui reste la mienne celle du
changement profond de société ce que
voulait pas dire en un mot un peu
simpliste mais c'est juste un rénovateur
ps eut lcr sos racisme etc enjeux
écologistes n'ai pas peur d'être le
candidat pour tous la prochaine élection
présidentielle si j'étais le candidat
fourre tout jeune arthur pour ce cas ça
je ne veux pas je crois qu'il s'agit de
faire quelque chose de cohérent de
sérieux je dirais de morale là
la chose qui mobilise le plus et qui est
quand même le point de départ de ma
réflexion critique de mon examen de
conscience c'est que j'en ai assez de
cette politique ou le faire et de dire
c'est pas la même chose dans les gens
qui vous soutiennent on retrouve des
gens comme alain krivine qui ont été
quand même vos ennemis non ça nous fait
rien devant de retravailler et que tu
étais si je pouvais être un
réconciliateur un fédérateur de gens
extrêmement différent j'en serai très
content mais je crois qu'il faut pas
focaliser sur cris guînes sur x ou y est
pas faire naître un peu le jaubert de la
gauche celui d ailleurs en fait on ne
sait pas où il était moi je sais très
bien où je suis parce que les gens qui
sont avec moi c'est pas krivine et ses
jeux ses candidats donc une oreille le
soutien d'aucune secret ville vous
soutiens qui m'aime me suive mais je
suis le candidat plutôt des gens d'un
certain nombre de gens qui sont 28 dans
le mouvement social ou qui s'y battent
le mouvement antiraciste le mouvement
des étudiants ils se tiennent pas dans
leur ensemble et en tant que tel mais
y'en a beaucoup ils sont auprès de moi
c'est les résidences joie moi je vais
vous dire au mois de
octobre septembre dernier exactement un
an je songeais à me retirer de la
politique active de la vie publique
c'est quand même assez dur est devant ce
mouvement des étudiants auxquels a
participé par exemple mon fils je me
suis dit il ya quelque chose à faire et
c'est une joie formidable de me voir
avec david assouline qui s'est dit tous
et beaucoup d'autres gens qui incarnent
ce mouvement excusez moi tu crois qu'il
a des chances de faire des poids jusqu'à
j'ai toujours pensé que s'il ne restait
que jusqu'à l'île serait celui là
à propos de ce que vous avez dit vous
avez raison en disant il ay là il a fait
tout ça il a accepté
or et la hongrie budapest tout ça c'est
moi ce que je crois c'est que personne
ni personnellement je pense qu'il faut
pas reprocher éternellement aux gens ce
qu'ils ont fait à marquer à tout faire
mais attendez à partir du moment où on
est fait il dit je me suis trompé j'ai
dit des bêtises j'ai fait des choses
condamnables
je prendrai des gens armés a guère parce
que d'abord toile à l'adoration n'aurait
pas dû une fois là est ce que je veux
dire non non on la comparait ce nom mais
j'allais prendre moi-même cette cette
comparaison
on dit toujours faut-il éternellement
rechercher à faire le procès des gens
qui ont été collaborateur ou et et vichy
je dis non
si quelqu'un aujourd'hui qui a été vicié
se dit mais c'est horrible j'en ai honte
j'en dors pas la nuit etc
jeudi mais il faut complètement oublié
le seul problème c'est qu'il ya beaucoup
de gens qui continuent à être vichyste
ou qui continuent à trouver qu'ils
avaient raison d'être collaborait la
campagne temps alors cela il faut être
implacables
oui totalement un placard mais quand
quelqu'un reconnaît pas dans tout le
monde s'est trompé un moment donné mais
joliment tout le monde
tout le monde a été ou maoïste ou
communistes ou ou petit nice to ou
accrue au socialisme au libéralisme pur
et yo tout le monde s'est trompé
donc forcément si on veut faire quelque
chose on ne peut le faire qu'avec les
gens qui reconnaissent qu'ils se sont
trompés
forcément alors faisons de la grande
unité des gens qui reconnaissent qu'ils
se font trop fait le parcours aux essais
sans trompait contre les gens qui
continuent à se tromper voilà qui se
laisse jusqu'à georges
est un peu triste de ce qui vient de se
passer et il a accepté tout à fait
officieusement puisque
n'a pas voulu il n'a pas souhaité être
filmé il a accepté de venir avec nous
dans la rue pour faire un micro trottoir
mais surtout si vous le rencontrez vous
ne lui répétez pas c'est totalement
secret on va voir
est ce que est ce que vous êtes concerné
par l'exclusion de pierre juquin du
parti communiste français mais là je ne
sais pas moi c'est vrai à oui alors là
non lâche je suis absolument sûr que
vous n'avez pas choisi cette dame au
hasard c'est impossible vous soyez pas
concernés par un problème qui qui qui
concerne normalement la vie politique
française et vous êtes d'accord avec le
comité central du parti communiste
français quand il
il a exclu pire juquin et bien sûr à
voile à l'envoyer voyez que nous aussi
nous sommes des rénovateurs c'est ce que
je dis excusez-moi valable dans le
studio
vous savez si vous à faire un jeu c'est
pas sa vie moi la politique ne comprends
pas dans ceux aux actes
je suis d'accord il n'a qu'à respecter
la ligne du parti communiste il n'y a
pas il n'y a pas de test donc en partie
habituellement une house savez c'est un
ami personnel 1 en dehors de toute
question politique
moi j'ai toujours eu une grande
affection bon tiens j'y tiens je dis
qu'il faut pu le reprendre parce qu'il a
commis une trop forte erreur quand on
est un membre du parti
en tout ils étaient placés et où il
avait d'accord avec tous ses camarades
depuis de nombreuses années maintenant
il à terme entraîner par la bourgeoisie
comme les doriot et marchal as ennuis il
a été intégré par eux et unsa la
bourgeoisie s'en sert de ce gala si vous
voulez revenir
personnellement je suis prêt à lui
ouvrir les bras c'est un an
vous lancez monsieur machin fait tout à
fait à julien avec nous sans le savoir
comme slogan c'est normal non bon voila
j'ai toujours pensé
enfin bon canular on va maintenant on a
fait un autre canular
on va voir qui vous concernent moins
c'est que comme vous allez piquer
beaucoup de voix genre marché moi je
suis sûr que vous
ah oui enfin la joie ni oui je suis sûr
que votre candidature va marcher moi
personnellement parce que vous regrouper
un courant qui n'est pas représenté au
niveau des élections présidentielles et
on a imaginé que marchés disent aux gens
que pour arriver à faire des voix pour
le pc et allaient être obligés de
s'associer avec le front national
et vous allez voir ce que ça donne c'est
marrant j'ai été choisi complètement
ouais ça j'en suis ravie reloge j'avais
une question à vous poser d'abord vous
avez sans doute voté aux dernières
élections
oui alors vous avez voté pour nous
peut-être due to a alors il y manque pas
voilà c'est là où je me méfie un petit
peu des médias oui est-ce que vous avez
voté communiste aux dernières élections
non à à l'envoyer à là encore une fois
voilà je parle dans le dans le studio
vous me voyez pas je suppose dans
l'image mais on est en train d'essayer
comme d'habitude de me piéger c'est à
dire qu'on met des gens qui sont pas
concernés par la politique c'était si
c'est carrément un complot vous avez
monté là vous avez voté communiste
oui oui même un tout petit peu plus que
communiste et vous avez voté communiste
oui évidemment voilà mais alors voyez
pas ce que ça c'est le problème la
télévision on met des gens qui sont
convaincus et déjà alors comment voulez
vous qu'on ait un dialogue et qu'on est
des gens à convaincre alors là bien sûr
cet homme a été prise au hasard dont la
wii non non mais d'accord mais enfin le
hasard fait quand même bien les choses
c'est un peu comme la cravate rouge des
journalistes là c'est un journaliste du
figaro coup on m'avait mis là la non
écoute et je crois que le débat n'est
pas autour de ma cravate le débat est de
savoir son nom mais moi je réponds je
réponds sur le plateau et j'ai quand
même l'impression qu'ils aient
il faudrait vous posez la question gros
pot ce monsieur combien à combien vous
estimez le pourcentage que vous allez
faire au premier tour moi je dis qu'on
arrivera à 40% à je crois pas mais
pourquoi on n'y arriverait pas parce que
justement là si on fait une alliance
avec des partis comme le front national
on fait comme les autres
on y arrive moi j'espère à une vidéo 9%
- ah mais vous êtes carrément pessimiste
mais moi moi je pense qu'il y aura quand
même plus
oui à l'ajustement nous on a en a un
problème on parti communiste et ses de
s'associer avec d'autres partis pour
arriver à frères 35 à 40% au premier
tour c'est ça qu'il nous faut oui mais
les socialistes et ils sont mous la
voilà c'est ça le problème les
socialistes sont mus oui excusez moi
alors non mais vous avez raison de le
dire et vous préférez qu'on s'associe
avec des parties durent de gauche tous
ensemble aulas plutôt que de la droite
pactise avec le front national
il ya aucune raison que le parti
communiste ne fasse pas la même chose à
votre avis riche entièrement d'accord ah
ça me fait plaisir que des gens puissent
qui parait-il sont pris au hasard
répondent affirmativement est ce que
vous êtes d'accord avec cette tactique
voilà on met en face de moi des gens qui
sont pas du tout concerné pour la
politique française sur ça c'est
scandaleux
j'avais une question
à poser ce que vous penseriez d'un
système politique qui réunit ray
conjointement la privatisation la
nationalisation le libéralisme et le
laxisme fondamentale inhérent à toute
civilisation décadente par rapport à la
situation internationale que je suis
désolé mais à me poser cette question
comme ça moi j'ai pas visite de parler
alors je parle juste de parler comme ça
l'antenne en direct je peux pas répondre
comme ça précisément cette question est
peut-être que si vraiment ça vous
intéresse de savoir ce que j'en pense on
pourra en parler en privé
ah mais si on peut s'arranger un rendez
vous savez moi je suis points contre
faudrait que les liens ne soient pas là
franchement est ce que tu crois michael
que pierre juquin à une chance d'après
son thème astral que tu as étudié en
fonction de sa date de naissance de son
lieu de naissance de son heure de
naissance est ce que pierre juquin a une
chance oui venons d'être président de la
république en mai 88 noms haye a
salement parlant les nappes aux futurs
beaucoup de chance en revanche je pense
que le public va ressentir que vous êtes
un être terriblement affectif quand
votre définition et qui va vous accordez
très largement sa sympathie c'est un
trafic de jupiter qui va vous ouvrir
énormément le coeur défense et la france
d'autre part je pense que à travers la
lutte qui va se produire au moment de
mes 88 les élections vous allez vous
réaliser d'une certaine manière et avec
le retour de saturne vous à les
concrétiser le nouvelle association
de nouvelles relations politiques et
quelques questions le thème astral de
pierre juquin s'inspire et bien en fait
je m'attacherai vous êtes un jurassien
c'est assez amusant parce que rannou
c'est une planète du collectif
découverte par herschel en 1789
oui c'est à dire au moment de la
révolution française et je voulais vous
demander si le fait d'être à nous rien
donc de vouloir vous démarquer à tout
prix du commun ne vous rendez pas par
moments un petit peu paranoïaque est
difficile de le dire par définition est
ce que vous vous sentez un peu
paranoïaque
non mais je redoute de devenir dans les
mois qui viennent ça peut vous arriver
deuxième question alors deuxième
question en fait je m'aperçois que le
degré symbolique de votre de votre
ascendant est associé à une image
d'enfant d'enfants qui cogne hamouri
d'exemple sur le chemin opérationnel
mentalement je sais tu n'imagines
pratique qui est en fait qui signifie
vous êtes très insouciant est-ce que
vous ne vous sentez pas quelquefois trop
utopique ou trop entendre juvénile pour
aborder certains problèmes politiques si
seulement je pouvais être juvénile pour
aborder les problèmes politiques
là ça serait bien j'espère je suis
entouré de gens très jeunes et j'espère
avoir réussi s'il dépasse très vite
les dizaines jelma noué avec right watch
you stole you tonight de véhicules
brothers et tous et en français l'évadé
et we have max va du recul qui a fait
tout le feuilleton qu'on a vu pendant
cinq soirées dans bad ministre est ici
son frère ni tine qui lui aussi ses
photos et scepticisme
non à huit chiots aymeric et we should
be structure partisane par invesco album
jah is in god hand made by six ans que
j'ai reçu c'est joe cole ok non pas du
tout une autre a dit qu'il va dire qu'au
hockey va du luc en avant alors on
regarde l'album maintenant s'il va
buzzer au baiser salé rue des lombards
monica passos et du jazz brésilien tous
les soirs aux vices rue saint denis
michel joue aux boules dans sa bodega
venez lombard trottoirs des bruyants crs
osvaldo pirro le district tous les
mardis super soirée bodega avec philippe
corti
étienne roda-gil françoise la croix
basque alain bougnaud maubert encore le
transat à saint mich jazz anglais avec
jaycee lee gardner
reste jaune saubens avec les chouchous
etienne roda-gil et sa femme la mode
anglaise la mode anglaise la mode
anglaise corti corti et les chouchous
des lacets mais claude jade bonsoir les
battre il faut bon soirée avec neuf
grands soirs si nous sommes là ce soir
c'est parce qu'il ya trois ans françois
truffaut décédé parce qu eric neuhoff
publie le 21 octobre la lettre ouverte
aux éditions albin michel et que les
cahiers du cinéma tu dis les meilleurs
articles le truffaut voilà françois
truffaut faisait pas cessé ses films
avant ses sentiments elle a sacrifié sa
vie au cinéma est ce que tu en as
souffert toi pas tellement parce que
finalement le temps qui me consacrais
c'était un temps qui était consacrée aux
enfants des aux enfants pour le cinéma
alors ça voulait dire qu'on avait un
week end à nous mais week end à nous qui
se transformait par une ken programmés
sur les champs elysées avec chaplin avec
hitchcock avec le stade d'arrivée c'est
donc c'était un amour groupe et d une
bonne culture cinéma alors eu trait est
finalement très sélective
il raconte un peu ton premier rôle dans
l'argent de poche
comment je suis passé y compris tu as
fait tu t'es fait jouer abctek j'ai pas
eu le droit de lire le scénario n'est
pas concerné ça va merci à lui et alors
il y avait une scène fatidique
et rouler une pelle un garçon et je
savais pas du tout que j'avais à faire
ça moi j'étais pour ce que j'avais mais
non justement
la première fois que la houlette de
temps et en public et alors il fallait
faire sortir sous les gens découvrent
parce que c'était comme une scène
dénudée alors vraiment pour moi le
comble et j'avais pas lu le scénario
donc je ne savais pas qu'il avait fait
un coup comme ça et puis on s'est
engueulés j'ai dit je ne veux pas faire
ça il va d'ailleurs je suis une actrice
tu l'as fait bien je laissais comme un
baiser de cinéma
ouais comment fait on fait on fait mais
je n'ai pas fait qu'on continue d'en
face et qu'on doit mettre un doigt sur
la bouche d'un mais enfin j'ai visé a
coûté la vie à côté mais on pense à
voter quand tu te balader avec lui dans
la rue se faisait plaisir qu'on le
reconnaisse mon père non il faisait
curieusement un jeu étrange il jouait à
l'inter on ne reconnaissait pas
forcément ou alors on le prenait pour
lelouch à bondoufle
mais non il jouait il nous faisait
passer ma soeur ou mois pour des
princesses alors il est on devait
l'appeler grand chambellan et faisait sa
majesté voudra un petit côté c'est sa
majesté peut-être s'arrêter à ce cinéma
d'été rigolo dans la vie privée et aux
usa le reconnaissait qu'il ya les
pendants au toujours plus plus parce que
les armes enfin l'accent français
ou alors sa silhouette comme c'est un
peu petit j'ai vu un espèce de tintin il
est aussi ce portable est atteint c'est
un produit français est tué vérité quad
lui finalement alors le nom de jean
sérien j'en sais rien c'est film
géotextile de l'amour du cinéma de
cassettes vidéo de choses de culture la
voiture comme a hérité non non non pas
du géant du web
cellier beaucoup dit oui salut bouquin
d'eric nov
je la lui et ça plaît oui ça me plaît
tout à fait c'est curieux je me dis que
ce serait très malheureux s'il existait
pas si on n'avait plus droit à décrire
si on devait brûler ses correspondances
mais en fin de match très très
malheureux parce qu'évidemment c'est
quelqu'un qui s'écrit par qui qui qui
qui s'exprime par lettre qui serait
malheureux avec les télégrammes
malheureux avec le téléphone soit sabots
les gens tiennent le texte oui c'est
bien écrit comme tout ce que tu peux
partir quelques remarques douce amère
comme aurait comme aurait aimé sans
doute les écrire ou les pensées truffaut
style qu'il est mort un dimanche et que
son dernier film s'appelait vivement
dimanche où il a été enterré dans un
dans un cimetière où on lui avait
interdit de tourner ou qu' il était à
l'hôpital américain et que c'était sa
dernière version originale non sous
weimar en travaillant sur la ville
quelqu'un en voyant tous ces films on a
le recul on s'aperçoit d'un tas de
détails qui en fait nous saute aux yeux
sur le moment on avait l'air de rien
il ya une idée moi je trouve génial
c'est quand c'est l'idée des photos qui
commentait photos noir et blanc de
tricot qui commence c'est comme ça que
j'ai commencé ce livre et en retrouvant
des photos dans les albums et elles sont
tellement en parlent entre eux m'ont dit
que je me suis un peu imaginer ce que
truffaut et et enfin de faire à ce
moment là où est ce qu'il est mais quels
étaient les gens qui n'étaient pas sur
la photo mais qui étaient autour de lui
un peu comme une main comme si c'était
un petit film sur contre trucs faux mais
pourquoi tu as tu as cette truffe albi
comme on dit là comme la jmt un des
personnages que tu cites comment ça se
fait que tu écrives une lettre ouverte à
françois truffaut ou plutôt qu'apple
mans parce que
pour le mangera était trop jeune pour le
connaître j'aime aussi les livres de
bollement mais j'aime beaucoup les films
de truffaut et naïvement je pensais que
combattre fo qui fera jusqu'à 85 n'y
avait pas urgence
et s'ils étaient vivants jouera jamais
avec les livres sur lui enfin peut-être
et puis maintenant qu'il est mort j'ai
écrit ce livre et il veut plus lire ça
c'est qu'on sait qu'on qu'ils le voient
pas vrai alain va voir on va voir un
sujet qui a été réalisé par simon
fraîche avec un commentaire de jeanne
moreau ou on va voir par les truffes ont
d'avoir des extraits de fil c'est un
très beau sujet
[Musique]
françois truffaut écoliers
françois truffaut adolescents fous du
cinéma
françois au regard révolté regard qui
nous donnera la vision passionnée d'un
cinéaste inquiets et précis
si j'ai besoin d'une intonation précise
pour une phrase je leur dis voilà la
phrase qu'il faut dire mais en plus il
faut penser sa lente at elle su que
c'était c'était ma mère on ne suit ta
mère ta mère qu'est ce qu'elle a encore
dit morte
excuse moi inventer pouvez pas savoir où
cela était l'homme le plus heureux du
monde en ce qu'il tournait
sa joie était communicative nous avons
beaucoup ri
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
non non non le coup de feu voir qu'est
ce qu'elle a de poterie là quelque chose
se voir ils doublent sont pas pas
ralliés à ce que tu dis tu es
complètement
ah non non non je t'assure et ses plus
gros peloton au bout c'est pas vrai
assez si ce n'est pas non non c'est vrai
quoi tout le monde est comme ça là non
pas du tout tu vois même pour les
différencier je sais pas faudra donner
un nom par exemple aurait gardé tout
moment mais c'est vrai mais je ne sais
pas si tu préfères don quichotte et puis
celui-là le petit gros là vous avez
vraiment un simple petit job et aussi
bien sûr jean renoir
là c'est le soir des oscars avec une
brenner
et puis maintenant il est avec le poète
jean cocteau regardant les images ses
principaux faits par un à 451 1 mariée
était en noir la sirène du mississipi
les deux anglaises et le continent
très nuit américaine
à des lâches
le méchant chambre verte
le dernier métro
[Musique]
la femme d'à côté il mentait
rien n'est plus mystérieux qu'un ami
mystérieux comme la vie l'art et l'amour
joris est quoi et bien aujourd'hui après
avoir eu pas mal de difficultés à me
sortir raison de cette image qu'avait
donnée de moi
il faut quitter c'était à la fois un
cadeau merveilleux mais un peu
empoisonné manger je continue je
reprends disons du service puisque après
avoir joué les les jeunes fini je joue
les mères alors ça m'amuse beaucoup
vous faites pas fait pas tellement mais
reprend les jeunes mères alors des
risques d'envoyer un télégramme plutôt
qu'une lettre sur lecture écrit quoi
j'aurais écrit [ __ ] vous auriez dû
rester là
alors gilles de murs gère qu'est ce que
tu fais dans la vie je suis comédien
cascadeur et qu'est ce que tu fais là
j'ai essayé de faire un nouveau truc si
vous en 40 secondes j'ai voulu prouver
qu'on pouvait faire autre chose que de
la tarte à la crème dans un studio
ouais j'ai fait de la comédie cascade
c'est un sketch qui s'appelle commis de
casque ouais je veux prouver qu'on peut
faire un interlude 87 qui se passe dans
la rue ou en extérieur ou en intérieur
tu vas en faire à la sortie de tes trucs
j'ai essayé de présenter dans une chaîne
pour faire l'interview 87 de nouveaux
trucs contre j'ai mis sur voila c'est
l'interview de me dire voilà on les
regarde comme fer
[Musique]
et cette semaine c'est quoi le sujet de
la semaine voilà j'ouvre mon sac sans
disque et la session sophie et je me
demande si c'est bon je suis lancé là
c'est un moment exceptionnel c'est
freddy mercury l'homme ce n'est toujours
pas là avec montserrat cavaillé oui
pardon du peu et ça s'appelle et
barcelona va suspendre un complet et
c'est la chanson qui va être le
le thème principal de legit à barcelone
ce que nous verrons la vallée se met
torse nu dans l'équipe
non non ce n'est pas ce qui m'importe
c'est de m'assurer que les chargeurs des
points de bonus
oui c'est un pléonasme dont on connaît
la personnalité du chantage
voilà l'heure de jeu mais ce serait beau
c'est très curieusement n'a pas
l'impression va te regarde la photo mais
c'est très très bon ah oui mais ça c'est
quoi francs que je serai très bon voilà
c'est la réunion c'était batch la craie
à la vraie jeune 1964 ce nom un peu plus
tard pour des garçons dont les rangs
gars super plaisir étant dans les faits
elle regarde par année dans les choux on
va vous le passé c'est le passé
alors maintenant savoir est-ce que tu
connais est ce qu'elles veulent sauter
tout cela c'est du fun britannique alors
on va leur servir le regard des norias
pas mon ca kamel et freddie on l'a vu
mes chaussures ouais
[Applaudissements]
mais gauthier de corsair
éduquer
boney m
[Musique]
com
au milieu
non
c'est un
m
je
là
t
jeumont
c'est tout
[Musique]
ils seront
et
[Musique]
mais
m
[Musique]
sp
ironiquement aussi bon soir bonsoir ils
m'ont soir bonsoir michel bonsoir
bonsoir oui c'est moi plaisir dis-moi
bonsoir comme tu dis bonjour tous les
jours à la télé bonsoir très bien et mes
cinq sens de l'amitié
tu connais michel drucker revient poser
une question alors une seule sommes de
vieux complices pose une seule question
fidélité à beille où je crois pas une
question doit maintenant comment fait-il
pour présenter le journal de la mi
journée de tf1 on n'est pas 2h30 du
matin presque tous les jours aux badauds
chine questions que j'avais préparé
vieilles habitudes des vieilles
habitudes
j'avais bien réflexe - physiologique
normal ça ça me fascine totalement mais
moi aussi mais j'ai jamais compris
comment vous et moi je crois qu'il fait
la sieste la family en fait non moi je
crois que alors je vais je vais répondre
à une question que beaucoup de gens
notre profession se poser aussi les
téléspectateurs le secret div c qui doit
tout ça ça fils d'un médecin qui vous le
dit il doit dormir peu ils doivent un
vrai sommet sur une distance courte qui
pourrait te demande à sa femme donc
voilà c'est ce qui fait la nuit ça on va
parler de ton bouquin qui changent chez
calmann lévy qui s'appelle hors antenne
que tu as fait que maurice achard ancien
c'est marrant il ya plein de petites
anecdotes comme ça sur tes débuts à un
score dimanche sur michel arnaud qui
t'apprend le boulot qui je fais un peu
province comme barmes a essayé de me
l'apprendre étape réussie
et toi il n'y a pas d'histoire qui sont
très marrant quand tu as failli virer
gainsbourg lui maintenant c'est assez
beau ça parce que tu dis j'aurais pu lui
mettre mon poing dans la gueule ça
aurait fait plaisir à la france profonde
mais je l'ait pas fait il ya eu
effectivement dans cette émission quand
il à dire oui tu as you like to fuck
qu'est ce que ça veut dire ce qui veut
dire que dans ton livre tu traduis pas
vraiment bien à l'antenne j'ai dit
je vais vous traduire ce que dit
gainsbourg il vient de dire j'aimerais
bien faire un petit tour avec vous allez
gainsbourg mabille où seuls à temps et à
temps et gainsbourg a dit mais je
suppose il s'agit de vue et la baiser
ouais alors je jeudi
nous étions une heure de grande écoute
quand même j'ai dit oui il vient de lui
dire qu'il y aurait dû compter fleurette
il dit mais j'ai plus est mais il le
fera après il me dit non j'ai dit je
voudrais n'abusez pas après mais tout de
suite c'était une re et la demande en 30
secondes quand j'ai vu le regard de
whitney houston je me suis dit tout le
sort en dix ans maintenant ça suffit
et tu fait un tabac le l'émission
s'arrête alors qu'il y avait encore une
chanson avec eddy mitchell vous trouvez
ça démago de le sortir un gros match
non mais je lis j'ai pas fait mais aller
j'étais tenté quand même
[Musique]
on dit dans ton bouquin qui voudrait
faire un talk show à 23 heures ça
m'inquiète ça alors j'ai dit que le
c'est vrai que le talk show est une
chose quand on a fait de la radio
quotidiennement de la télévision façon
mensuelle ou hebdomadaire on a envie
inquiète on en boule par un an mais
n'inquiètent fage n'a pas inquiété et
jeudi j'aimerais bien un jour faire ça
mais c'est totalement incompatible avec
ce que je fais actuellement et je suis
pas certain qu'à directeurs de chaînes
soient intéressés par ce projet
maintenant il ya un truc est très
étonnant c'est que tu dis que si c'était
sépharade tu serais sur la sur la cinq
coups sur la lune mais comme tu es
ashkénaze qui restait sur l'un d'eux
c'est par ici
non mais c'est une image mais on va bien
non mais j'ai dit que c'est vrai que que
dans notre métier
en général dans le monde du spectacle
les juifs d'afrique d'origine d'afrique
du nord on les trouve davantage du côté
des abruzzes disant financier oui on les
trouve plus du côté du mieux disant
financier expédition culturel voilà
mais c'était une boutade d'accord c'est
sûr tu me fais un petit reproche parce
que dans son livre il faut quand on
livre tu dis je vais dire des choses que
j'ai jamais dit etc
et puis finalement quand on dit de vous
car je me demande s'il est vraiment
passé de l'autre côté du miroir
parce qu'à part entre que tu fume la
pipe le week-end qu'est ce qu'on apprend
vraiment qu'on savait pas je veux dire
que tu sais moi ta main mon nom mais
j'ai peur que lui n'a pas voulu gagner
trop d'argent en allant sur l'annoncé
que j'ai pas vu ça c'est gentil quand
même oui mais je crois pas être
foncièrement méchant non je pense pas
que tu sois content mais je pense que
j'aurais pu dire des choses un peu plus
j'ai pas tué je raconte une sur piaf
femme en disant je n'ai pas eu des jours
la voir je suis passé c'est non non il
ya des jours où elle du mal à supporter
ouais mais mais non je n'ai pas mon
histoire et d'une finalement une grande
banalité
ouais moi c'est plutôt télé télétravail
boulot pas j'adore sages aucun mérite
mais
je commence déjà à faire de très gros
progrès puisque pour la première fois
grâce à toi je viens aux bains douches a
tu vois j'ai mis une demi heure avant de
trouver quand tu peux revenir quand il
est chez moi mais tu es le bienvenu je
rencontre amoureuse ne va pas
non parce qu'il est sorti il ya quelques
jours et je crois je lance aux verts
demain où ses jours selon lui la très un
livre c'est chez michel lafon
oui oui dis que finalement si le mathias
recettes a pu atterrir sur la place
rouge c'est un coup monté
parce que comme ça que gorbatchev a pu
virer son état-major c'est ça oui non
mais c'est pas mal comme idée
non mais c'est une idée parce que c'est
perdition détient couru dès le début ce
qui m'amusait en réalité c'était d'abord
une soirée au bain lorsque médias c'est
à dire ils ont la bosse mais fin de la
soirée au bain on se régale des copains
et on bavarde de ce fait divers que des
ans qui comme tous les journalistes dans
la figure après à une dépêche est en
train de nuit j'ai commencé à délirer
sur mais comment a dû aller là bas il se
calait lui dis ce que je donnais un
doublé des rapports avec les états
majors et les tibias nomenclature à
munich ce qu'ils n'avaient pas pu
arriver là-bas par hasard lors à partir
de là ont besoin ça il y avait quelques
cinéastes dans le coin et les une idée
de scénario dans laquelle il fallait
trouver une histoire qui se tiennent et
qui aboutissent à l'arrivée de mathias
sur la place mais est ce que toi tu as
pas été manipulée par les russes pour
que finalement et enfin se croire que ça
c'est possible seulement si le valent
bien
non dans ce
premier d'abord c'est un livre de
journalistes ouais et dans journalistes
et recevant les dépêches
et connaissant un petit peu le système
soviétique n'y a pas un cessna
on pourra toujours leur accorder ce
qu'on veut qui n'a pas un c'est cela que
je veux pas saison de la chasse devrait
cependant le système soviétique des
dividendes entre une chose qui prend en
chasse un cessna et le moment où il faut
tirer il faut qu'il y ait une décision
alors ce système hiérarchique je
développe dans le bouquin il faut bien
le type présents pour dire tiré sur mon
site où l'équipe sont absents ce jour là
personne ne dira c'est à travers cela
que j'ai imaginé l'histoire de ma
jianfei vent jusqu'à la place pour l'eee
pad entretiennent de bonnes relations
avec le rss vous dire que c'est vrai
qu'à mes deux lancements l'ambassade due
à une excellente et je souhaite que le
livre soit lancé ouais là des brumbies
d'exemplaires jauger les liga c est l
éducation est mégalo mais la question
que je voulais te poser parce que moi
j'y pense tous les matins en me
réveillant c'est comment tu fais drucker
la pause et tout à l'heure quels secrets
alors va nous le dire la mémé ya pas de
suite c'est un secret tu t'es là jusqu'à
4 heures du matin tu présentes le 13
heures le soir tu l'as dit non mais être
là avec moi là bas un enfant comme on
est trop là je vais avoir du matin
idrissou ailleurs du reste ouais c'est
aussi une formidable école de rang
contre moi je me souviens l'un des
premiers scoops sais pas raconter ma vie
d'homme ni scène mais je raconterai 30
noms mais l'un des premiers secours
mondiaux que j'ai pu faire à la
télévision miss elles sont toutes bien
de tête
c'est le moment où j'ai eu à 13 heures
henrie kissinger qui m'a en premier
révélé le plan qu'il allait chez régine
je les trouvais chez régine 1 5 heures
du matin avait fait le pari que lui
pourrait pas se réveiller alors laquelle
je faisais mon journal mais on a tenu le
pari à 5 heures du matin et le lendemain
j'avais le scoop du plan des accords
domingues qui jugeait ce manteau alors
comment comment c'est possible je suis
sûr que si drucker faisaient ce journal
il irait à la pêche beaucoup plus
souvent si on ne veut pas être victimes
il ya intérêt à être en permanence à
l'égout si je suis ici et si je regarde
par exemple ce que tu fais sur l'a5 je
bats je veux pas voir défiler bonne mais
je dis que dans en matière de night
clubbing de regarde comme société qui
vit ton émission c'est d'abord pas la
même révolution que ce qu'avait fait dim
dam dom dont un peu désirer même temps
très long il ya très longtemps et la
façon de traiter les invités la nuit et
ses terrains avec des hommes politiques
c'est aussi révolutionnaire que dim dam
dom si on n'est pas à l'écouté de cela
et si on n'est pas dans l'environnement
de faim il ya certainement un moment où
on ne pourra pas continuer parce que la
société va plus vite de saison si elle
va plus vite que ce que nous disons nous
ne pouvons pas accroché sur ce que
disent les gens dans la rue ce qu'on
vous vend pas accroché sur ce que disent
les gens dans la rue on n'existe plus
travail toi si tu as mis au boulot je me
suis mis au boulot terrible attentat
avant avant le procès déjà du travail ou
là maintenant oui je travaille
nouvel obs ouais c'est bien c'est une
bonne maman hommes comme toi comme comme
journal stagiaires non ils sont géniaux
c'est qu'il s'agit case de son livre
comme averroès qui sans parler de
journalisme pas salarié à la pige c'est
bien quand on a tous commencé comme ça
tu sais et bien quand même je dirais
ceci dit ils demandent que des grands
interview finement si tu vas à
interviewer qui va par exemple la de
niro c'est pas mal j'ai fait maintenant
ne pourra y cinq ans patch and save à un
filon nombreuses reprises
alors on reste dans notre société c'est
bien ce que je disais
kubrick et puis mitterrand alors ma
petite martha par te préparer pour aller
dans les boîtes de nuit qu'est ce que tu
fais de ta vie ben je suis dit [ __ ] tu
fais les pubs on renvoie les défilés
dans bach et puis sinon je fais des
chaussures des chaussures salariés mais
cette fois voilà cécile gauthier ça
c'est moi rappelle moi mes souliers
ouais et tu les trouves un peu partout
gagné nulle part ailleurs dimensions et
organise des fêtes au cg organise des
fêtes ce que j'adore sortie à murray
alors là ses chaussures là c'est toi qui
les dessiner tu les fais fabriquer voilà
c'est ça et les filles achète ça et ça
marche très bien
ouais tu fais une chanson aussi oui je
viens de faire un disque qui s'appelle
accélère mon âme à yahia et le groupe
s'appelle rififi sécher qui s'échinent
bars clubs et c'est la totale en
maintenant on va voir des pubs
la première c'est la sardine
[Musique]
bonsoir je suis ravi de t'avoir parce
qu'en général dans les émissions de télé
on a toujours des stars quand les films
à vendre et toi tu es là et a pas de
film avant c'était parce que les bains
sont les habitudes les bains somme dans
mes habitudes et puis en plus surtout
les plus intéressants de moi aussi de
faire des émissions quand on n'a rien à
vendre parce que quand on a quelque
chose à vendre obligatoirement sera
obligé de vendre ce que l'on a
avant tandis que l'as bompas c'est alors
que c'est une collaboration comme ça on
va prévendre plutôt d'accord en ce
moment en ce moment je tourne l'argent
ouais
mais roman de zola de la cia ou mac avec
et cruciaux et miou-miou qui ne soit pas
qu'ils sont programmés avant un an un an
et puis puis avant j'ai fait dans donne
qui va s'en sortir
en janvier j'ai pas grand chose à vendre
choc dans cinéma pense que c'est vrai
que monsieur nos jours je me suis amusé
à faire une année une année de cap alors
tu en es où sur ce projet de blizzard
d'après la pièce de schaeffers parce que
dernière fois je te vient de faire du
vst dans scoop à la une est tu le disais
je ferai pas le dakar cette année parce
que je polanski va mettre en scène
bizarre de schaeffer danse est devenu
quoi cette histoire a été jouée tout
simplement retardé à la place de la
pièce de schaeffer bien scène par oman
j'ai joué dans band molia met en scène
par planchon c'est pas mal non plus qui
peut mal donc que tu vas le faire le
blizzard oui vu je pense à le faire on
va le faire après je suis pas dans 89
non pas des projets juste comme ça je
tends 89e oui des projets pas des
projets pour des projets des envies et 6
les envies voilà c'est moi j'aime pas
avoir des projets trop signé puisque un
petit peu peur profonde ce faire le
dakar cette année non vraiment pourquoi
cette année de venir janvier non non non
parce que ranger je reprends je reprends
dans des hôtels pays et donc ça
correspond ce fait je fais deux genres
pendant deux ans je n'ai pas sur le dire
car tu vois tu leur fera encore très
honnêtement je ne sais pas non je ne dis
pas je ne crois pas à jeudi
j'ai dit je ne sais pas je ne sais pas
parce que bon ben moi j'aime bien marché
par par pulsion alors bon je les fais
j'ai fait six fois de suite
tamara vall on l'a on l'a gagnée trois
fois par équipe pour l'année
fausse 4,83 on a toujours eu des places
d'honneur 3e 2e et 5e
bonjour je sais pas c'est c'est une jupe
est vrai qu'entre 10 et une passion là
la seule et unique passion que j'ai
c'est mon métier laventure davanture bon
sauvé paris dakar semble une aventure
enfin le métier mais que ce soit le
dakar où que ce soit la vie tu as l'air
de bien mais tu éclaté quand même parce
que dans les périodes comme en ce moment
on voit pas mal dans les boîtes on voit
pas mal car la nuit aubin why are
d'ailleurs
j'aime bien rouler à fond la caisse dans
la vie dans une riche veuve est toujours
toujours et puis non non c'est pas vrai
je sais pas je préfère dire à la télé je
peux dire là je veux dire une chose à la
télévision c'est que je fais une grosse
différence entre les elle colonise rôle
plus important dans une souris oui
c'était c'était une définition de
travers
ouais et suppose un colis ou pas je me
suis dit que j'avais des campagnes et
ardent dévoilement pas pas toujours
quand je pense que je
j'aime pas l'alcool gogo mais par contre
ce temps en temps la mairesse et
vous allez pas audiencé bien sorti avec
le diable est bon c'est vrai que j'aime
bien les endroits où j'aime bien venir
est ici et à paris si c'est quoi tes
boîte préféré à paris il y en a très peu
un traité car samba il semble rester et
castle ça va c'est un bon oui c'est un
bon choix si vos circuits est ce que tu
crois que tu as la même chance que ton
père au niveau des réalisateurs et quand
tu tournes est ce que tu penses qu'il a
eu des réalisateurs des scénaristes plus
avec plus d'envergure que ceux avec qui
tu tourne toi aujourd'hui en france
aucune question n'avait pas tout du
cinéma léger pas non plus à me plaindre
il faut voir ça pour ça va continue t il
a fait l'ena lui aussi en affaires en
général donc ça que le patois et il a
tourné car mega millions
on est crevé j'ai eu la chance de
tourner
des tournées au noir de tourner avec
truffaut est bon je pense que le compte
est bon moment oui oui bon c'est ce qui
compte c'est qu'on soit moyens et ton
fils alexandre et suivent en faire un
acteur un bon troisième génération moi
je n'en ferai rien d'abord ce transfert
ce ne sera pas la troisième génération
ce sera la quatrième plus avancée pour
ce que je tiendrais à petit signe avec
eux il n'y a que des clowns dans ma
famille de 1820 donc ça remonte encore
beaucoup plus loin que ça quant à lui je
lui ferais rien faire la seule chose que
je souhaite qu'ils fassent quelque chose
qu'ils aiment et ce qu'ils ont envie
d'être acteurs pour le moment où henry
et
j'ai envie j'ai envie qu'ils aient envie
tu connais prins ah oui la prime tu vas
voir sur le putsch et il avait 2 de la
v2 il avait deux guitaristes qui ont
fait un clip qu'on va voir ses 26 elisa
regarde
non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tu
[Musique]
alors
chaud
tiens
[Musique]
ils ont
tiens
oh
à
[Musique]
pis
castex
yu
oui
en maintenant mon cher franck tout le
monde sait qu'en pensait à lui comme
heures c'est se dire oui à la vie
ouais la vie absolument celle inverse
d'un has been totalement et si vous
voulez devenir un jour un wannabe il
suffit de nous écrire 93 faubourg
saint-honoré retourne ici vous en
trouverez ici vous fait fortune gilles
hébert seul qui vend sa salade
savez vous qu'il est possible de flotter
sur les arbres comme sûres et que ça
marche puisque l'on a fait l'année
dernière sur la forêt amazonienne où une
équipe de chercheurs plus grâce aux
radios des signes automobile mieux
découvrir cette forge pour illustrer ce
propos j'ai ramené quelques échantillons
intéressant du brocoli du persil à une
échelle moindre
ces deux articles sont une très bonne
représentation de l'aspect d'une forêt
vu par lui et pour vous montrer qu'on
peut y faire plein de choses je vais lui
disposé cette maquette également de
bateaux primatice regardez comme elle
est stable comme elle flotte bien même
si l'adoubement nous allons réaliser un
grand projet au printemps prochain
prochain
nous essayerons toute sorte de radeau
différents sur une forêt française
pour ça nous avons besoin de forêt nous
avons besoin de sponsors d'argent alors
si vous avez des idées contacter gilles
hébert solde aux 42 29 39 74 bonsoir
bonsoir je me nomme patrick top j'ai 35
ans et je suis pastis je réalise
aujourd'hui des grandes oeuvres murales
que je n'ai pu malheureusement vous
apporter 15 mesure environ une centaine
de mètres carrés
je pourrais vous dire que actuellement
je réalise des nuages de papier en
couleurs bien évidemment d'autre part
j'ai réalisé des structures appartenant
négatif qui viennent autre chose de plus
dans deux mois je me rends sur la côte
d'azur et là-bas j'aimerais rencontrer
une personne qui éventuellement
pourraient connaître et apprendre mon
travail mon numéro téléphone le 43 70 67
5 ans la plus grande invention le
spectacle pour enfants bonjour je
m'appelle dit si grand j'ai 29 ans je
suis auteur compositeur interprète et je
m'occupe plus spécialement de créer des
spectacles pour enfants paladyne vous
propose
minuit sonne jusqu'au coeur du soleil
nous nous adressons à toutes les
collectivités et également les
particuliers dans le cadre des
anniversaires ou nous présentons nos
personnages appelez-nous vite pour vos
animations carnaval fête aux 69 04 82 10
avant minuit bonsoir je m'appelle lucide
extra et j'anime des stages qui
s'appelle femmes d'orchies c'est à dire
la voix d'énergie des femmes
c'est un stage culture seulement
week-end et la fin de ce week-end
vous avez la capacité de vous défendre
tout est adapté pour la morphologie des
femmes alors une chose qu'on anciens
entre dans ce stage c'est comment avec
votre petite mère femme fragile brise
une planche je voudrais vous montrer
tout ça si vous avez envie de savon vous
défendre et bien vous me téléphoner aux
30 52 46 50
merci grand soin
philippe starck bonsoir
c'est la nouvelle femme oui
on vient de se marier hier elle
s'appelle comment arts à rabat jacques à
l'âge mais plus tard à l'entendre sur le
rail et philippe disant c'est moderne
très moderne est ce que tu viens là
c'est oui oui je n'ai jamais pu
supporter l'idée du canapé pour moi
c'est vraiment le le symbole même de
l'oeuvre de l'habitat bourgeois comme ça
et je ne comprends pas mon histoire
vieux c'est une position totalement
archaïque
les paysans de l'ancien temps qui était
en ligne le long du mur comme ça pour
regarder ne sait pas que je parlais en
tout cas ce que vous ce qui l'est plus
c'est à toi calgary ce canapé
non je des boys bonne alerte aurait pas
dessiner ça je soupçonne que non ça vaut
combien canapé stahel cette bourse est
très nouveau je crois que le premier
vient juste de sortir à milan il ya un
mois et je ne sais pas parce qu'un homme
comme tout comme tout ce que je fais
j'espère c'est un prix juste
certes les balises et pas cher qui se
cherche encore comment la portance et la
justesse du produit c'est à dire qu'il
peut
une ferrari vaut son prix justement il
ya d'autres marques qui vole les gens
quand ils achètent une mercedes est
toujours plus économique nos deux
voitures alors tu as été absolument la
première personne qui est venu aux bains
douches à l'époque le comment ça s'est
passé de première fois que venu ici pour
le faire oui à obama il y avait les
fabris et jacques qui à l'époque était
antiquaire et qui venait ici acheter le
bar je crois le bar en bas et ils sont
ressortis en disant hollande en endroit
incroyable karbal douche
c'était un vrai bain douche a déjà une
boîte c'est un vrai nom s'était abdouche
c'était surtout je crois un endroit de
baptême par immersion si je ne me trompe
ce qu'on fait là haut il y avait encore
d'une baignoire avec un escalier nos
remparts et donc il est arrivé il a dix
ans j'ai vu un local extraordinaire
qu'est ce qu'on pourra en faire et
et c'est là où tout l'idée le concept
badouche est venu où on a amené il ya
des gens sont groupés benin s'occuper de
la musique et ainsi de suite
il ya vraiment eu un esprit vaduz qui
s'est fait et bien drôle il faut dire
dans le choix était celui qui avait fait
la main bleue la main jaune les bras et
aux jambes à la main jaune dans la main
bleue la main je la rendrai pas du tout
bah non parce qu'on m'avait demandé de
faire une boîte de nuit la plus belle du
monde je les fais et le jour de
l'ouverture je me suis aperçu que le
titre pendant ce temps là les faits un
voleur frink pour du roller skate et
comme je déteste tous les sports néo
américain où tout le monde est à la mode
pour deux mois sur des patins à
roulettes comme des imbéciles
évidemment c'était pas du tout mon
projet on s'est connu à façade ya dix
ans je me souviens de la première fois
que je t'ai vu je vais expliquer que
finalement les gens habitent toujours
dans des grottes parce qu'un appartement
dans un ancien immeuble s'est jamais
qu'une qu'un espace en forme de grottes
bien serait donc aux professionnels pas
de nom mais c'est tout le problème
foncier aujourd'hui c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui on continue à construire
des grottes c'est à dire que quand on
fait des murs en plâtre vous voyez un
maçon portugais
qu'est-ce qui fait prendre il broie de
la pierre il le met dans des sacs ils
nos transports qui le mélange à de l'eau
et il essaye de refaire de la pire lice
mais la liste lapierre par définition
mais parfaite tour être lisse et donc
tout ça est un énorme non sens en tout
cas un incroyable archaïsme et il faut
absolument que ça change c'est à dire
que l' architecture deviennent
authentiquement moderne 6 mai mécaniste
pour la bonne raison qu'aujourd'hui les
gens travaillent un tir de leur vie si
ce n'est plus simplement pour se payer
leur coquille dans le coaching
d'escargots esat absolument scandaleux
parce que ces sommes c'est cette énergie
qu'il dépense à celle pourrait le faire
autre chose donc il ya vraiment une idée
aujourd'hui politique de ce que doit
devenir l' architecture pourra regretter
que les gens soient esclaves de leur
coquille
alors l'époque de façade je t'ai
rencontrée j'ai rencontré jean bad vous
avez
heureusement réussi tous les deux mais
dans les années qui ont suivi quand je
te rencontrer dans des dans des boîtes
de nuit ou dans des soirées je me
racontais toujours tu sais des choses en
arabie séoudite à dallas partout et des
fois je me demandais s'il était pas
mythomane parce que j'ai tellement
merveilleuse qui est arrivé alors qu'est
ce qui s'est passé depuis dix ans non
moi je suis quelqu'un de curieux c'est à
dire que j'adore moi je ne travaille pas
je me contrefous un peu de
l'architecturé du design de tout ça moi
je suis avant tout un aventurier créatif
j'espère un rêveur autrement dit qui vit
qui se transporte dont le véhicule et la
création véhicule pour connaître des
gens parce que j'aime j'aime l'humain
pour vivre des aventures et donc j'ai eu
en effet il ya très très longtemps
j'étais bien content parce qu'à l'époque
j'étais totalement ruiné on est
toutefois leur entrée dans le tour du
monde de deux ans à quoi l'a hanté
cardin 7 voilà c'est ça et on est rentré
ce tour du monde on était strictement
lessivé et par une chance absolument
incroyable il y à un émir qui est venu
je sais pas pourquoi mais pourquoi il
est arrivé et m'a dit monsieur monsieur
l'ingénieur philippe il faudrait me
décorer mon boeing j'ai fait je vous
dirais plaisir à brengues entrées
commandes parce que c'est plus une
histoire de psychanalyste je crois en
gros il est vraiment tout tout est à vos
combos l'est c'est pour ça que ça dure
c'est gelé bruit comme retour de l'est
quand ça commence à ne plus l'être dire
que ça j'étais jeune c'était mon seul
client de ce genre et sa durée sa durée
de trois ans pas plus parce qu en fait
l'idée c'est que là bas ils ont toujours
trouvé que cette tare que c'est à deux
pas d'alcool
mon style n'a strictement aucun rapport
avec leur désir saoudiens n'ont donc ça
sa vitesse était simplement une petite
aventure mais qui est toujours très
intéressante comme toutes les inventions
nom d'allah ça a été bien plus bien plus
important puisque c'est des familles de
pétrole est en fait c'est la famille qui
sert de modèle à la wii la famille hunt
wins rudolph merci neeson est propre et
net dans le skate cabaye qui m'ont qui
m'ont appelé
avec tous les fastes que ça peut
représenter à l'époque parce que je
crois que dallas et mata de sinistrés
par la crise ça va encore fort et
soupçonne et donc ils m'ont dit voile à
lorient je suis descendu de l'avion il
ya des limousines noires bang bang bang
et ils m'ont promené ils m'ont dit
choisissez la ville est à nous je dis
juste reviens moi je choisir mais
pourquoi c'est un hymne à côté on
s'embête on s'embête alors on a lu dans
le journal dans le new york times que
vous êtes le roi de la nuit du conte
projet ou satin vite à la campagne et
pas avec ma femme m'a finalement vous
êtes le roi des miss est de marquer dans
le journal en gros d'accord dans qu'est
ce qu'on dit qu'on va écouter on pense
que pour lancer une ville il faut de la
nuit il faut l'esprit de la nuit il fait
nounou la plus belle boîte de nuit du
monde
alors donc choisi cet endroit lors d un
arrêt choisie dans le tarn parce qu'en
bonne européen je crois toujours dans
down town et on a en effet rennes lens
on a fait cet endroit qui a été
terriblement compliqué parce que ceux
qui ont des fous furieux 3 grammes de
cocaïne par jour et par personne sabi
moussa sa ville toujours à peu le
raisonnement en plus des fils à papa
donc c'est jamais très facile et ils
n'ont pas de script nécessité dans le
temps et dans les résultats en fabron au
bout d'une d'une offre une aventure
incroyable mais incroyable digne du
western
on a
fait cet endroit et j'y suis retourné il
y à quelques temps un an ou deux ça
marche pas très bien et j'ai eu comme le
grand bonheur que les gens me remercient
et en effet c'était le but puisqu'il
fallait changer l'esprit de la ville
s'est échangé à dallas au troc et les
émirs il ya eu dallas et après qu'est ce
que c'est assez bon non c'était vous je
sais pas après qu'est ce qui te font
appel rejeté aucune mémoire ça c'est pas
les meubles d'entrée les bas l'elysée
cost et les plats plein de choses vont
travailler le poisson une centaine de
projets par an gens du secteur
architecture
bah c'est pas que je me lance dans
l'architecturé de style architecture qui
me lancer dans les mandats rousset ou
ces délais les clients d des gens des
japonais des américains qui voient ce
que j'ai fait en intérêts qu'ils disent
mais quand on est capable de faire ça ce
sont sept ans la structure alors en
effet j'ai eu des quelques premières
appréhensions lors d'un projet de dix
ans que je suis capable de le faire ou
pas et quand on arrive toujours frey
candide et qu'on a deux trois trucs à
dire on trouve des solutions très forte
abstention très intéressante et donc on
a fait le premier immeuble haut à tokyo
qui va être fini là dans deux mois et
j'en suis très très très très fier pour
la maison j'ai vraiment l'impression de
l'amener quelques jours une vraie
fraîcheur architecture c'est une drôle
de bête
vous pouvez essayer de décrire l'objet
le nom le pr nom de code dans le bureau
s'appelait de dia le deuxième the green
monsters of the bayou le monstre vert du
bayou c'est-à-dire l'espèce de monstre
qui vit dans les marécages qui se
nourrit de cadavre et qui un jour
détruira tout le tout le sud de
l'amérique
et maintenant il s'appelle le nombre
définitif c'est nani n'a ni la nina ni
ça veut dire l'innommable quentin
japonais c'est parce qu'ils voient quand
il a peur il ya anani nani est donc
cette un immeuble complètement
biomorphiques complètement de formes
organiques vicieux en perpétuelle des
compositions il est recouvert d'eau xi2
à m
cette décomposition cool avec l'autre
fuient et se et se répand dans le sol de
granit noir où il ya des microfissures
qui ont été faites au laser et qui
raconte son histoire est une autre
histoire qui va s'inscrire au fil du
temps et de cet ovaire qui coule partout
et c'est aussi le premier immeuble près
d'acteurs du
depuis ce que j'ai volé par un parent
par une astuce de la loi j'ai volé
l'espace du terrain d'à côté c'est à
dire que mon immeuble et diagonale et
surplomb de l'autre du piratage
totalement la wii ce qu'on peut le
comprendre
la scène d'emma sinon elle laissé des
meubles on la destine à tabouret qui
marche très très bien très très très
bien et très beau et j'ai été très
violent de l'argent neuf ans gagnez vous
mesdemoiselles et donc voit j'étais très
jaloux parce qu'il a fallu que j'attende
trente six ans pour avoir un meuble
lelangue injecté en une seule pièce
engelures et talc et arrêtent
technologie pour le designer et elle l'a
eue à 8 ans ça m'a bien énervé et là on
sort chez flos en italie dans deux mois
une lampe de ce nom quand j'ai cette
houle et des supers pas ton temps bah
pourquoi perdre son temps
finalement parce que m'amuse à faire ce
que je fais et donc c'est très drôle
c'est bien je perds pas mon temps je il
nie l'impression de le gagner ni la peau
sûr de perdre je vis jma menus jedessine
on s'agite en maintenant on va voir
quelque chose que tu as fait amsterdam
est en cours et amsterdam
tu t'en souviens à peu de choses près
oui tu sais ce tramway je ne crois pas
que ce n'est pas toi qui appelle non non
non moi j'ai fait le monsieur devant
parce que l'on voit ça c'est quelque
chose de très moderne on doit réaménager
un bâtiment au mieux d'amsterdam qui
s'appelle de var s'est placé vraiment
comme un arc de triomphe c'est vraiment
un bâtiment central donc tout à fait
sensible les les gens sont partis de
leur histoire de leur culture
et c'est un projet très diagonale parce
que c'est un studio de télévision
professionnel mais qui est à la fois
publique dans la mesure où ça va
ressembler un espèce de grand café comme
on pourrait dire le café costes
sauf que c'est un studio de télévision
alors à plein des tâches est assez
sophistiqué mais c'est très c'est très
intéressant parce que c'est très complet
c'est très haut polymorphe comme ça or
on est cher world first we saw land
that's why pour un petit mois de sorte à
ce mystère qui faillit don't work morin
before we the hole homme bat na waïe à
marie à nice
[Musique]
j'en dirai pas plus
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est un décors d'opéras ou deux joueurs
de ce mot c'est un cetain à face à face
un combat on a cette espèce d'énorme
escaliers minérale dur masculin
oppressif quasiment fascisant on a en
face comme hadefi cette espèce de mur de
capitons démesurée et tous font comme ça
incliné assez assez féminin mais dur
aussi
et ils sont ils sont face à face comme
ça ils se regardent le tout après et
coiffée par cette mégastructure qui est
un petit peu ce qu'il errait ce qui
rattache ce drame au sol alors en fait
tout ça est tout à fait et japonais tout
ça c'est une c'est une violence et une
mise en scène tout à fait japonaise le
style est ce qui les choque énormément
ici ce qui fait cette espèce d'émotion
dans tokyo
c'est le fait que c'est l'emploi des
matières c'était ces espèces d'acajou
comme ça mélangé avec ses velours rouge
ils n'ont pas du tout l'habitude de ça
alors c'est gégé truquer les cartes mais
en gardant la même la même violence si
on enregistre en commun avec eux
so i find alcatel
my friend elle sert it clean
avec marquez of which iam se taire à
ivry
liles apps pour iphone et maintenant
nous allons goûter l'anonymat et oui car
c'est un pervers a besoin de recycler la
touch mouse a été dit ma
ouais rien à voir quoi quand même le
baril c'est super parce que vous savez
on a eu un tube énorme cet été c'était
au mont bocage au comment il s'appelle
déjà énorme h marne on na na remo hockey
marc aymon riquet et ce soir il nous
fait une surprise et avec un tueur
exceptionnel d'ailleurs je veux qu'on
présente nos coeurs on peut filmer
l'auteur laquelle quelques secondes
nous avons trop de chats le mariage qui
coassent véronique amans
[Musique]
niamien être 15 ans et thomas et puis
moi quand même merci oui maintenant
et oui c'est vrai non c'est pas ça c'est
pas avec ça c'est pas avec ses crochets
m'excuse et pas mexico c'est cox imec
aux xive et par marché imaginaire
maintenant à toi c'est quoi qui peut
d'ailleurs c'est quoi mexico est ce que
tu peux me parler de mexico aïeux c'est
une chanson qui a été écrit par un
inconnu
francis lopez francis lopez dans les
faits c'est un très long inconnu en
effet
[Applaudissements]
on a chanté les parisiennes
la petite est née le chapeau
on a chanté les madrilènes qui vont
concerner 2 le ton des mots fléchés nord
le sang chaud et bien que les
américaines mary du monde ont nommé tôt
tous les vents ciel mexico
on peut bientôt
le bon sens des limites lobito
si vous avez ça joue la chance
dégoûté
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
maxi chevaux
mexique
[Applaudissements]
coc
[Musique]
et
les poubelles
chaque jour
mexico au mexique
m
et tu seras toujours d'accord
il a que faire
et quand ils attaquent cité
sur le soleil de mexico ça lui rappelle
la semaine
mais qu'est la semaine et quelques
cadeaux
le soir même
au mont sainte anne donnez vous ai
laissé mon se déchaînent ont nommé tôt
sur les anciennes mexico
mais bientôt
au son des rythmes imposés
partir ou sa belle s'ajoute à peine
ce n'est pas tout
à l'écouter le même l aventure de
mexicaine sans l'aide avec tripous
[Musique]
mexico
abbas
oui
et toi
tu te sens et
jeantet et
pas bête du tout effondré de chaque jour
mexico comme inquiet
et
t
tu seras toujours par la douleur et
qu'il tournait
sicot
mais qui toi
oui
e
[Musique]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous mettez un
peu de bleu